mettre quelque part dans un bout de loi
pas dans la Constitution compliquons pas
trop tout citoyen français a le droit et
le devoir de connaître l'histoire de
France alors chaque
mot
suscite des objections des
problème mais ça veut dire que bah il
faut enseigner
l'histoire et ça veut dire
que pour être un citoyen français qui
n'est pas originaire de France c'est pas
mal de connaître
l'histoire sachant que je termine par là
certains des pays qui n'enseignent plus
l'histoire se trouvent aujourd'hui dans
une situation assez cocasse dans lequel
devant une pression migratoire forte
venue de pays non
européens avec au bout de quelques
années des demandes de
naturalisation ils ont adopté des lois
selon lequel pour être citoyen de leur
pays il fallait connaître l'histoire du
pays donc le paradoxe c'est que dans ces
pays les nations non né dans le pays ne
connaissent pas l'histoire mais les
citoyens de souche plus récent sont
obligés de la connaître du coup ils vont
être conduit à généraliser
l'enseignement de
l'histoire alors là on manie de la
dynamite hein mais mais en même temps si
l'enjeu sur le long terme c'est bien la
réconciliation ou le retour à un état de
guerre ou à des rivalités permanentes il
y a un moment où il faudra prendre des
risques